right i don't know if you know this but
we are at war right now first up there's
the afghanistan war that everyone is
forgot we just signed some agreement
that we're gonna be in there for another
like 12 years or something but forget
about that one uh then the Iraq war
kinda ended right but now we're back in
there and we're doing strikes on Isis
and then we also jumped in on Syria and
now we're attacking Isis in Syria of
course they're fighting Assad we were
gonna bomb Assad a year ago remember
that then we didn't do that we kind of
got the chemical weapons that anyway
it's a big [ __ ] basically and uh
we haven't gotten war authorization on
this especially for the Syria part
there's some legal mumbo jumbo the
people are arguing or at least the
administration is arguing that we have
authorization in Iraq because we were
there for a previous war but we do not
have congressional authorization for
this war and Rand Paul Senator Rand Paul
of Kentucky wrote a piece in The Daily
Beast about this let's take a look he
wrote i believe the president must come
to Congress to begin a war i also
believe the War Powers Act is
misunderstood President Obama acted
without true constitutional authority
even before the 90 days expired since we
were not under attack at the time anyone
on say but in either case the war is now
illegal it must be declared and made
valid or it must be ended Congress has a
duty to act one way or another taking
military action against Isis is
justified the president acting without
Congress is not so what Rand Paul is
referring to there is the authorization
for use of military force which was
passed by the George W Bush
administration and that's the
authorization that Obama is using to get
into this war now before the election
last week for weeks uh John Boehner kept
saying well the president doesn't call
us back to Washington to vote on the war
so there's really nothing we can do now
I'm pretty sure he doesn't like when the
president asked him to do anything so
it's a little disingenuous so I'm not
cutting Congress slack and I'm not come
to cutting Obama slack because I think
we should if we're gonna have a war
which is a whole other topic we should
have authorization for the war what do
you think well is it technically a war
or is it a military action what is it
technically being referred so
this is the league that's the legal
mumbo jumbo that they do and we went
into Libya when Obama first got in and
they call the kinetic military action so
there's ways to use words but I'm pretty
sure when bombs are dropping on cities
and people and were attacking terrorists
or whatever it's a war if Canada bombed
us said we'd call it war right I think
right no I was just gonna say I mean I
think first of all I'm sort of tempted
to discount almost any off had written
by any presidential hopeful or read
between the lines of the very least like
it's not surprising that France mall
libertarian today right how about you
know name recognition and sort of
relevance at this point which you trying
to maintain with this and it's not a
surprise that he is libertarian
candidate isn't really a fan of
unbridled executive power so like no
surprises there I think that one of the
more interesting questions raised and he
only does so indirectly is this question
of can legislation or the legislative
process ever catch up with technology
and technological advances because like
you said what is warming I mean he
invokes the Constitution he and votes
invokes this this war bill from the
1970s yeah like war has changed so
dramatically I mean constitutionally
obviously right that was like muskets
across a battlefield but even since the
70s or more drones there weren't any of
these things so like yes a how do we
find defined war vs military action and
be like you know how does that change
whether or not the presidential can use
the president can use these these sorts
of acts in order to defend the country
the way he sees fit yes all right so to
get to that point exactly and what
you're asking so the president has 60
days if it's considered urgent the
president has 60 days to get
authorization and then after if there's
no approval from Congress he then has 30
days to end the mission so what Rand
Paul's arguing is were past that point
um so every time we've talked about this
and I've brought it up every time we
talk about Isis I think part of promised
people just don't care how the
government works anymore you know me
like we created a system where we were
supposed to have a legislative branch to
write the laws and then an executive
branch to sign them into low energy
judicial branch to make sure that
they're legal I just don't think anyone
including the people in those branch I
just don't think anyone cares is that is
that fair to say
it's about that anyone doesn't care i
think it's like what can we do yeah you
can go out and vote which most liberals
did not this last election cycle I don't
so I don't think it is about we don't
care it's just what what can we do to
change it there's nothing you can do or
I can do to change what's going to go
down at this point and another thing I
would like to add is Rand Paul is saying
that this war is illegal and isn't he a
plagiarist is it plagiarism telly-op a
notice about that yet nobody's perfect
but i'm kinda with him on this like I
just think if we're gonna do this we
could have a debate whether we should be
doing it or whether the other countries
there should be fighting Isis and we
could sit back and they hate us whether
we do it or not but I think he's at
least being intellectually honest here
uh versus if this was a Republican
president doing this I'm pretty sure all
the Democrats would be going nuts right
if it if a Republican president was get
having a war without authorization
wouldn't Democrats be going that yes
there's hypocrisy all over the place and
there's also like it's you're both right
you know it's part of it is that we
can't keep up with what the laws are and
why you know the 60 versus 90 days like
why was that even put in place like
taking a step back and thinking about
why these laws are even enacted in the
first place is sort of more interesting
than the nitty-gritty details of it and
figuring out you know if that law is
even relevant right now because it was
in 1973 yeah but is it relevant right
now we don't how are we supposed to know
that the president of all people should
know whether that is relevant enough to
pertain to this specific international
security issue that's sort of what I'm
saying like I just don't think he cares
I think they have lawyers they all have
so many lawyers that they're just like
Obama's lawyers are like yeah you don't
need to go to Congress go ahead we got
some legal mumbo-jumbo from bush in the
70s and Baba will do that and Congress
is like oh it gets us off the hook we
don't even have to vote on it so then
it's good for us so it just goes to show
how broke in the system is I suppose and
that he can't even get the Republicans
on board with it like he's four why no
no no I'm bored with calling out Obama
on it right you know any mean like he's
straddling in the middle which I find
pretty I worked in the White House for a
little
yes i'm inclined to to trust them i mean
it's like the most passionate
intelligent hard-working group of people
I've ever been surrounded by in my life
and like they can't figure it out and
we're screwed anyway I don't know call
me a strict constitutionalist I want the
system to work late it's both you I
don't know but subscribe right down
below